what's up dude what's up
well it's the beanie baby episode you're
beanie babies today bro
yep i just came fresh from the hill dude
um did you actually yeah dude
nothing better than back country dude
[Laughter]
oh my god dude go up there roll a
spliffy
how did you did you go at the top of the
mountain and get [ __ ] lit
dude dude i went up there dude you
wouldn't believe it i took a couple
airplane bottles
of fireball stuffed those things in my
burton jacket
yeah got to the top of the hill slammed
them
okay and then slammed a run
that is sick double black you know
brayson
yeah dude he's my homie brayson stomp
pad
check this out custom because you know
he's sponsored by
um uh burton yeah he got him a custom
stomp pad
titanium thought it was way i thought it
was forum no because he had like a weird
thing with them but then he had to
switch
because like he was [ __ ] the owner's
daughter and like [ __ ]
classic that's classic dude so
stomp pad custom titanium steel
we get to the top of the hill he's like
bro you ever did a black diamond on
shrooms i said
nah bro opens the stomp pad
a couple grams in there no you chew up
rub the wheel crush that fungi
absolutely we ate that we it
we ate that fungus dude you did we ate
that old cheese man
so were you tripping like on the way
down oh for sure dude
like every tree had massive cans it was
crazy
[Laughter]
now i see why so why why uh why sonny
bono went
into a tree he's probably had those
shrooms exactly dude i almost went into
one looking at those cans dude
yeah it was like the first time in my
life i looked at a tree and didn't only
want to smoke it
i wanted also to [ __ ] it yeah yeah
so sick dude you know you know brady
no wait is that um
oh is that boy um oh dude is that is
that um slavey's cousin
yes dude he's the one with the sick v
dub the golf
that he souped up got it so we took it
out to the mountains right
and we're we take the chair four i
believe up the back
side and we're up and we're just about
to putting on my bindings right
and okay dude you wouldn't believe that
this fool pulls out an eight ball
of cocaine right powder on powder
how exactly dude first time i've skied
and skied
no way bro yeah dude so the whole time i
was going down like
shivering but not from the cold no of
course not
no did you actually snowboard this
morning
no i didn't i just got the beanie on so
i figured
we both do we might as well play the
part you know i was hoping you're gonna
be like no but i did do coke
this is pretty close dude yeah this
makes me you know
i just espresso really [ __ ] me up you
know i'm glad i'm standing otherwise i'd
be fidgeting like crazy in my seat right
now yeah i
appreciate your standing desk today yeah
no problem does this feel like a weird
like startup zoom call kind of i've
it's reminded me of someone we've seen
on a zoom call recently that we can't
talk about but
oh i know exactly what you're talking
about
ah dog i wish we could maybe in the
future in the future we can definitely
joke about that
yeah guys what a character you have to
listen to the podcast for at least like
two more months so then we can tell you
about that whole experience and you're
gonna know you're gonna know
yeah that was definitely um one of the
we have two calls in our entire lives
that were the most funny
and that was a strong contender for
number one
michael one the type of [ __ ] where
you're like talking
offline yeah you gotta mute your mic and
like turn off your camera because you're
like laughing so hard
yeah like everything
everything that was being said we were
just writing it
oh it's so so good i can't even really
describe it no we can't i mean
one day in the future we could tell this
story yeah uh i i will say this i had to
keep making really bad jokes
so i would have an excuse to smile yeah
i think they were probably thinking this
guy is [ __ ] weird man
i would just say like something stupid
to try to like ease it out
because you had your camera off
the whole time the whole time so you
were that's a [ __ ]
life hack man why is that a requirement
and everyone at the start was like oh so
we're not gonna see you today and i was
like nope and they were like cool
all right respect that i really wish i
did that dude
oh man i really cause then i was sitting
there like a psycho with my
with my [ __ ] corners of my mouth like
plastered back like uh-huh
uh-huh i know it was a long call too
just assume things dude guys just know
if we get a hamster
[Laughter]
you'll get to name it
okay no more okay no more no more no
more
[Laughter]
do you know what i was thinking about
like what
what if what if we got dick surgery
like what if it you know they finally
figured out how to do it
and we like oh wait dick enlargement
surgery yeah we gotta talk about dick
surgery
yeah it's like to make it prettier or
just to fix it
you know just yeah make it straighter
make it perfectly straight
too straight yeah
you know if you have like arcs in their
feet oh yeah i'm flat [ __ ]
i have a flat dick a real pancake dick
yeah i got a pancake dick i have to it's
super flattened out
i have to wear the converse of like
[ __ ] somebody put in a panini press
i have i have to wear the the converse
equivalent of a condom because it's just
my
there's no there's no arc in my penis
yeah
[Laughter]
i was thinking what if we got just like
crazy enlargement surgery and people
actually got mad at us because it ruined
the brand
like people going on reddit being like
yeah ever since they got their penises
enlarged they're
not really the same like the podcast is
totally different like yeah
yeah i agree dude i saw like i i saw one
of them in a vlog and they stood up and
i
i was able to just get a glimpse of
their bulge in their sweatpants and it
totally threw me off
like i was not expecting that it just
kind of like you know
left a bad taste in my mouth and they
just keep wearing gray sweatpants to the
studio
like like clearly like their wardrobe is
driven by their new hangers and it's
just it's really not the same like i
wish when they're
well i missed when their wardrobe was
more you know
diverse and and yeah it wasn't so
motivated by the hanger but now it's
just
i don't know man it's not yeah i wish i
missed when they used to wear like
really baggy cargo pants you know to
like hide
whatever they got going down and now
they're only wearing gray sweatpants and
their tick-tock presence has completely
changed
[Laughter]
it's just like all dick talks like i
don't think i've ever seen their face in
a tick tock since they got enlarged and
the whole thing is just like a close-up
on the package and then just shaking it
like this
i don't know helicopter tick tocks i
don't know why they took it one step
further and like
got like little cozies for their penis
heads of their faces
to like try to trick us into thinking
that their penises is their head like
we know it's your penis just swinging it
around and
it's weird man so you know
it's not really down with tmg anymore
they're just they're literally too big
and they're also not funny anymore yeah
and they're also not funny anymore
they're literally too big
dude they got so big
nice anyway dude
you